بعد دخول الذكاء الاصطناعي مجالات متعدده
بدا بالاستحواذ على بعض الحقول الطبيه
الاصطناعي بطريقه تشبه الدماغ البشري تشير
توقعات مستقبل الوظائف في التقرير الذي
نشره المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي الى انه
بحلول عام 2025 ستختفي خمسه مليون وظيفه
نتيجه الاتمته وعصات علم الالات على
العديد من الوظائف التي يقوم بها البشر
حاليا لكن في المقابل من المتوقع ان تظهر
سبعه 97 مليون وظيفه جديده
ككره الثلج تتسع دائره الاتمته حول العالم
وما بين الروبوتات والذكاء الاصطناعي يخشى
بعض البشر على وظائفهم لكن كما ستختفي
وظائف ستنشا اخرى دعونا اليوم نتعرف على
اول روبوت في المانيا يتم تطويره حاليا
ليحل محل الباعه في المتاجر الصغيره
ومحلات البقاله
[موسيقى]
هذا هو الترتيب الوظائف العشر الاولى التي
سيزداد الطلب عليها في العام 2005 وهي
الوظائف المختصه في تحليل البيانات
والذكاء الاصطناعي وهندسه الروبوتات
بالاضافه الى بعض الوظائف الجديده في مجال
اتمته العمليات وامن المعلومات وانترنت
الاشياء اما الادوار التي يعتقد ان الحاجه
اليها ستقل وتتراجع فتتمثل في مناصب ادخال
البيانات والوظائف الاداريه والمحاسبه
واعمال التجميع وخدمه العملاء
قد ياخذ الروبوت مكانك في العمل ان لم
تطور مهاراتك لتواكب متطلبات سوق العمل
المستقبليه من المانيا ايهم القاسم صباح
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات